- Well, you've been open
about identifying as queer.
- Yes.
- So, were you able to
embrace that as a teenager?
Was that easy?
- No, because I don't
think I had the language.
- Oh.
- To even know what was going on.
I think it's come much later to me, now.
And it's wonderful
to just be me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Really, yeah.
- Refreshing.
- Yes, very much so.
And I think it sort of
made space, creatively,
to just sort of let go
of whatever I was hiding.
I guess, you know, you don't
realize you're doing that,
putting so much energy behind it.
And once you take the energy away
from concealing something
that is so a part of you,
that you can't hide it,
you can put it elsewhere.
- Absolutely.
- Make more wonderful things.
- When you say like, you
didn't know the language.
You mean like, there just
wasn't a lot around you
that kind of, even, you didn't even,
you knew it was happening,
but you didn't know what to say about it?
- What's to say about, yeah.
I knew something was different.
Particularly when I talk about that,
I knew something was different
but I didn't know what.
Like, how, what do I call it?
What do I say about it, now?
- I've never heard someone
describe it like that.
And that's so poignant.
- Yeah, I think sometimes we
assume that every queer person
knows it from the beginning.
Most of us do, but we don't
necessarily know the language.
Until someone says, hey, this is,
these are words that
you might want to use.
These are expressions that
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This is, here is some space for you.
- Yeah.
- So you can speak about yourself
without someone else telling you.
- And I think finding your
people, like, when you're young,
like, your people to kind of help you.
- [Cynthia] Yeah.
- Like, cultivate, and
all of us, you know,
our personalities, our
character, like who we are.